today we're going to be speaking with
Bill Keller who was the founding
editor-in-chief of The Marshall Project
and also author of the book what's
prison for punishment and Rehabilitation
in the age of mass incarceration bill I
really appreciate you being on today
thanks for having me so I mean I guess
to start with at least in some
theoretical sense prison sentences in
the United States are supposed to be for
rehabilitation right the idea that
someone has done something wrong harmful
to society and or to victims they have
been sentenced to some amount of time in
prison and that that experience the time
that they spend in prison is at least to
some degree rehabilitative in addition
to being punitive so that then they
serve their sentence they come out and
now they're rehabilitated right I mean
at least sort of theoretically can you
talk about whether in practice any
elements of the criminal justice system
in the U.S actually function in that way
not really I mean you can find
individual programs that function that
way some of them experimental some of
them more broadly based like college
education programs that actually do
rehabilitate but there's
there are a number of obstacles one of
them is cost it's expensive to do
Rehabilitation programs
you know you need trained personnel and
so on
one of them is good puritanical streak I
think in American culture uh
the
main objective from that point of view
and Rehabilitation is just pampering
also
prisons are not the most ideal
therapeutic environment they're scary
they're noisy
the people who believe some are really
cops not therapists or social workers
they don't have the training to
administer those sorts of programs
so there's there are a lot of obstacles
the heroes of my book if I can call them
that are the
the corrections officials who are trying
to improve rehabilitation in spite of
the obstacles and the teachers the
volunteers the
you know
kind of a mystery
uh it's why I chose to wrote about write
about prisons rather than courts or cops
because
there's been a lot of attention
deservedly paid to policing
judges and prosecutors for the most part
run for public office and do a lot of
their business in public
prisons are kind of a mystery uh so
that's that's why I wanted to focus on
that
if we um put aside for a second when
there are actual rehabil Rehabilitation
programs the sort of status quo
day-to-day of being in your standard
prison
at this point we know beyond any doubt
that's not a rehabilitative experience
in any way is it and in fact it could
sort of be the opposite
there's considerable research
um by people like Bruce Western and
Colombia who show that the pro that
being incarcerated can actually make you
more likely to commit crimes when you
get out right
and and when we when we say that I mean
there's this sort of general idea
prison can turn you into turn you into a
more hardened or violent criminal and
it's often repeated but what sort of
what sort of data do we have about that
well the one piece of data that's kind
of shocking is that
two-thirds of the people who are
incarcerated
will be rearrested within five years of
their release
the recidivism rate it's a tricky metric
and then people measure it different
ways but the recidivism suggests that we
are not doing a very effective job of
rehabilitating overall
when we talk about
um the deterrent effect of
um the system that we have and the idea
that at the end of some crime that one
commits if you are caught and charged
and convicted there could be a
punishment that's coming
from what I've read Studies have found
that the death penalty as compared to
life in prison without parole
does not seem to be a functional
deterrent in terms of reducing the
crimes wherein one would be eligible for
such punishments what do we know more
generally about prison sentences and the
deterrent effect on those not in prison
there's a sociologist named Francis
Cullen at University of Cincinnati who's
done a lot of work on this subject and
he he makes this logical argument that
the deterrent effect assumes that before
you commit a crime you stop and consider
the risks
in a sort of logical way whereas a great
majority of crimes are either
opportunistic that are done in concert
with you know going along with a gang
um they're spontaneous
and to the extent that people do stop
and consider the consequences before
they do something illegal they're
they're mainly considering the chances
of getting caught right it doesn't make
a difference to them whether the
punishment is five years for a felony or
20 years for a felony that that's just
not the way people think
yeah you know we were talking about
jaywalking yesterday on our program
because of the California governor
Newsome recently signed into law
um a bill that that mostly
um decriminalizes jaywalking and I think
that there there's sort of some gray
area in the sense that like you know I
jaywalk all the time and it is true that
if I knew that life in prison was a
possible sentence for jaywalking I
wouldn't do it but you need these really
extreme examples that that in order to
really be able to make that case whereas
as you talk about with many crimes
murder in particular murders are are
such a type of crime where already
you're talking about only a fraction of
the population is even willing to commit
a murder based on the research we have
that the line between life in prison
with no parole and death penalty for
example it seems like it's a completely
different type of consideration than my
jaywalking example
right I mean I would never say that that
the risk of going to jail or
being severely punished doesn't figure
into anybody's thinking at all I mean
the deterrents exists but it's just
greatly exaggerated and you weigh that
against the
the effects of being incarcerated
to commit another crime
uh it's not it's not a convincing reason
to lock people up especially to lock
people up as we do for far longer
periods of time and for lesser crimes
than most other countries yeah I want to
talk about that next so can you give
some specific examples of average
sentence in the U.S for certain crimes
compared to in some other countries for
which we have data for the same crime
sure
sorry I just lost my train of thought
yeah any crime that you that that we
could think of a a difference in average
sentencing between the U.S and other
countries
oh I know what I was going to say
because mass incarceration is a
relatively new phenomenon for us I think
that's important to remember
that that for most of the 20th century
the preservation rate in the United
States was something like a hundred
people incarcerated for every hundred
thousand population which was a little
higher than the rest of the world but
not not off the tracks
and then it's beginning in the 70s we
took the sharp right turn
and it became more like 500
people every 100 000 in the population I
mean that's an incredible phenomenon and
part of that is
that we unfortunately people for much
longer periods of time most
I'm talking here about developed
countries mostly the European countries
the ones that I've taken a look at
most countries don't have a death
penalty they don't have life without
parole
um
in the book I talked about the case of
Anders Breivik who's in the Norwegian
mass murderer who
slaughtered 70 some kids at a party you
know political party picnic
and instead of just 21 years now if he's
deemed to be a danger to society a judge
can extend that but that's
a severe that's the maximum punishment
right
yeah are there um you know sometimes
there's this idea that if you do the
European style of incarceration where
conditions generally speaking are better
and sentences are shorter
uh that there's a higher recidivism rate
but it doesn't appear to be borne out in
the data is it
no there were citizen rates in all of
the Scandinavian countries in Germany
and most of the developed world uh are
considerably lower than ours
so to me what that says is that for some
of the folks in the United States who
are demanding the stricter prison
sentences I don't really think they care
bill about the rehabilitative effect or
the the odds of recidivism I think
there's a sort of you did the thing and
now you deserve a strict punishment
there's kind of this strict father
morality aspect to it that's totally
untethered from the actual impact what's
your sense
that's absolutely right there are a
couple of reasons why we should care
even if a lot of people have ever hard
selling this there's a I guess moral
reason that Americans like to profess
that we believe in second chances and
Redemption uh and so if we want to live
up to those ideals we should be
treating prison inmates as if they were
redeemable
but beyond that there's a pragmatic down
to earth self-centered
argument for rehabilitation
every year we let out six hundred
thousand people from state and federal
prisons
uh do we would you rather have those
people emerge from prison brutalized
alienated
stigmatized and lacking in any kind of
skills that will help them re-enter the
real world
or would you like to have them equipment
Neighbors
missing argument
yeah it seems the the preferable answer
is is clear on that
um to talk a little bit about the kind
of society that is created within many
prisons you know I um I interviewed the
author Ted Conover who wrote This Book
new Jack in which he actually became a
great book he became a corrections
officer
at sing-sing in New York and talks about
his experiences and he did it knowing
his plan was ultimately to to write a
book and he talks quite a bit about
the reality of the sort of culture
around being a corrections officer in
the United States and the pressures
faced systemic and and otherwise and he
doesn't excuse any of the behavior that
he observed when he was uh in the job
but he sort of gives a glimpse into the
realities of how the corrections officer
circumstances impact how prisons are run
as well can you talk a little bit about
that what what is unique in the United
States about being a corrections officer
and the expectations and the pressures
if you want to be a corrections officer
in Germany
you have to take two years of college
level courses including things like
human rights law psychology
sociology
and then you're
your job is essentially to be a
therapist is putting it a little too
strongly but to engage
the inmates
to try to figure out what it was that
made them go wrong and see what proud
programs would be available to address
it if you're going to become a
corrections officer in the United States
and I'm generalizing broadly here
there's a saying in Corrections that if
you've seen one prison you've seen one
prison everyone has its own kind of
culture yeah
but for the most part if you're going to
become a corrections officer as Ted
conover's book demonstrated you're going
to get a few weeks of training mostly
about crowd control and self-defense
it's it's a it's more of a paramilitary
organization
it's
it's as Ted emerged from that experience
with
victims of the environment and the
culture
too
and I think there's some truth in that
yeah and it seems to some degree oh
sorry Bill I was going to say there
seems to be a mirroring in one of the
things that it seems many police
departments would benefit from mirrors
something that Corrections Officers
would benefit from as well which is more
training along the lines of of sort of
Social Work and relationship building
and Community Building
yeah and you can find the leaders of
organized
Corrections Officers unions and things
who will say that that's
in the last 10 years or so they've begun
to talk the talk a little bit
unfortunately they're organized in the
states that have really strong
Corrections Officers unions
they tend to be source of resistance
that's a good job
one of the things that is uh more unique
in the United States is this concept of
a for-profit prison run by a corporation
that contracts with various agencies and
sometimes those contracts include a
guaranteed occupancy where even if there
is not actually a certain occupancy the
prison operator gets paid as if they
were so they have a certain uh
expectation of guaranteed Revenue that
they're going to be receiving can you
talk a little bit about even though most
inmates in the United States are not
held at for-profit private prisons what
is particular or unique to the
for-profit prison experience in the
United States or is it the same as in
the state-run and federal prisons
foreign
you know there's another book by a
journalist who went undercover as a
prison guard Shane Bauer's book
and he went underground in a Louisiana
prison that was a private owned by
Corrections Corporation of America and
he he does a nice job first of all of
demonstrating that the bottom line
becomes a big factor in in the thinking
of those prisons
but also the whole history of
incarceration in America
it has various profit motives associated
with them starting most egregiously with
the South where prison labor became a
substitute for slave labor
without much improvement in the
conditions and certainly without any pay
so it seems as though it's essentially
quite similar but with the profit motive
added on top of it I mean is that fair
to say
yeah that's that's I think that's fair
to say it's actually you're right in
saying that it's a small
percentage of the incarcerated
population who are in privately run
prisons but that misses a
uxiliary services that even the
state-run prisons contract for people to
mod make phone services available to do
medical care to do transport to run the
cafeterias often those are contracted
after private
companies that don't have any incentive
to
to do more than they have to
also there's elements of privatization
even within State and federally run
prisons as well I did not know that
correct
one example that's been a big issue
lately in a lot of Prisons is
there's a company that makes available
tablets
so that you can download books for your
your class and and communicate with
as a general rule prisoners don't have
access to the internet but they can get
limited services on a tablet
but the company's charges
exorbitant rates for the
use of them
barely have any opportunity to earn the
money to pay for them
yep and that's we've seen that also with
the with exorbitant phone rates and
prisons as well uh Bill uh we've been
speaking with Bill Keller who is the
author of what's prison for punishment
and Rehabilitation in the age of mass
incarceration Bill very interesting and
I really appreciate your time today
well thanks for having me on I'm glad to
spread the message